[Music]
yeah
yeah the streets have always been
watching Gotham has been waiting
patiently for the Mecca to regain its
rightful aller in the heart of Harlem
Rises not just a savior but a moon
[Applause]
the city game now reborn is generating a
tidal wave of president future stars a
Brotherhood defined by two words
unveiling the next brand of hoax in NYC
[Music]
the jelly fan phenomenon to describe it
within New York City on steroids and 2k
17 social media is a group of young men
who have changed the culture of
basketball everybody in the city they
like somebody who's positive once we
started getting popular jelly came took
the world by storm
noumic trashin going gonna back up you
should back up swallow say I'm handsome
I got my bezel
[Applause]
the slide is just like you just gotta
have you gotta be born with it most of
us in here we like to draw attention to
crowds you know everybody sees us or
like kind of like rock stars everybody
making the tri-state lit it's the dawn
of a new age for New York City
basketball revitalized by a group of
young dynamic players who have taken the
big athlete by storm their indoor and
outdoor stages are filled with packed
houses and celebrity Road Isaiah and the
whole jelly fan movement has definitely
kept players in New York City the CHS
AAA which is the Catholic High School
League that we're currently in abroad
New York City has never had the crowds
that it has had that Goldman let's hop
in the country right now I'm gonna show
you I got a problem coming know that
interns from your boy Esau told Amy
jelly-filled
[Music]
I stay at Washington the current
Minnesota gopher is the co-creator of
the jelly fan movie named after Isaiah's
signature finger roll move
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
jelly is a finger room but you know you
just got to add your own little spice to
it
I made judging my own signature move
because I saw it might be Jordan do the
open legs dump right now John dad said
dump so I just had to add some jelly and
just open my leg
[Music]
[Applause]
it's the most infamous layup on the
planet right now just like all in the
flick of the wrist I was like you get it
you kind of got a lick the defendant in
his eyes and [ __ ] it back and then let
it go we were sitting in my house then
I'm looking on my phone and you like you
know everybody said fam and fam this and
we always would say jelly-like anytime
somebody later ball up like jelly
Naima Lett yeah we need our own group I
was just sitting in and I'm like yo
jelly Finn say your eyes you know he got
big eyes and visa yo room Chile Finn
that'd be late yeah
[Music]
as Washington is required James
countless evolved so did decides that
they're growing hoop fraternity through
their tri-state New York City
connections the dual added several of
their friends who just so happened to be
some of the best players in the region
we was all in the same team me jock quit
I was there Pedro I was on Instagram
when I say I changed name to each other
feel underscored um John she wasn't
jealous for most coach John I was like
what is that
they hit me up about it like I'm
starting this movement and then um I got
I got in the gym with on one time and
they was just playing around with it I'm
just watching him do it I'm like oh
that's hot we could really do something
with this and it was like that's the new
move movie starting cuz they are I want
I want to join it he's like he's like
you got to beat jellies in the game you
down alright next game there one jelly I
looked at them like it's coming like I
got two more I'm more I'll be down there
I'll do the other two in the game and
then after the game I'll change my name
to jelly from ones course it's been
maybe nice ever since
we all have like a special layup we all
could finish around the basket and
numerous ways and they chose me as one
of them and I'm proud to be a part of
most of us are like top players in that
town around the country in how
everybody's gonna be like this like a
brotherhood just like more the
basketball look at it like owner of the
cost of VG's what each other accountable
basically we just all came together as
like brothers and sent me be an only
girl and we just aspired the basketball
world from younger kids Isaiah
Washington near my best friend he told
me that I was the best girl in New York
City people I should be recognized just
as they were by us doing the jelly and
Isaiah they answer another level in New
York it just took over the whole entire
tri-state and it definitely put New York
back on a map
[Music]
put your boy jelly fam members became
staples around both the summer circuits
and the tri-state Catholic High School
leaves with members playing with and
against each other
[Music]
we all think that telly Pam hey Angelica
me the best we don't think anybody's
better than us so we're going at each
other as if we are the best those
matchups are just crazy just because of
the names people want to see us play
against each other these guys are
competitive sometimes I'm thinking about
to come to blows but they just go hard
you just compete I don't think there's
like a better atmosphere than New York
City
summertime basketball in New York our
motto if you put him on an island you
got a drown and meaning like if his one
alone with somebody you've got to get a
bucket
Rucker they were just like all right we
need you in him to go at each other like
make the crowd go crazy I thought as
soon as I came in I mean him started
guard each other he was going back and
forth scoring on each other I remember
him coming down the right side of the
floor going middle and then stepping
back and the tough jumps out in my face
the crowd went crazy so I'm like I got a
fire back my song JQ came down I think
he liked it through the legs hurt
I didn't think he's gonna do a 360 like
I thought he's gonna try it late crowd
going crazy like everybody's standing up
I remember it was just like an instinct
I just jumped up 360 and he had flew
past me and then when it went in like
the part just went a while
I rewind the Crowley nuts and I was even
looking like well he really just did
that I was nice I told him I said that
was tofu kids throwing basketballs it
was a people running the court my people
taking the shirt off
it was nice as the jelly fan Brotherhood
started piling up legendary performances
the group discovered they possess
something of far greater values they had
developed an authentic brand with fans
recording every moment the movements
voice was soon spread nationwide jelly
fame grew because of social media and
allows you to share it on Facebook
Twitter things like that really to be
honest we just expanded it cuz it was
again as girls social media definitely
social media is probably the number one
reason that this thing has caught fire
and those guys have done a great job of
marketing anytime there's an
announcement that he is going to play at
a certain venue that the park is almost
overrun almost like the old school
Rucker games kids are hanging on the
fence as is had a found impact on summer
basketball mainly because he has swag to
his game and the great part about him is
that he backs it up
[Music]
all this up
[Music]
one day i crub up the Dyckman cuz the
high school games the last couple years
been more popping in our limiting game
so jelly fair was playing and the crowd
the park was packed packed everybody Oh
everybody knows about it you can't go
anywhere the country not being
recognized oh yeah feels like wow like
all of this came from us being a great
one to make a group and now it's like a
whole thing everybody across the country
wants it to be Joseph but we'll miles a
lot of kids and we have to like carry
ourselves the right way act like what
kind of professionals because
everybody's watching us we can't go
anywhere without taking pictures now I
did like would you be anywhere in a
locale going to you like oh your son's
in the other film can I get the picture
[Applause]
so good I'll give you something I'm
gonna be to get a girl like that oh man
you gotta get older man here take this
way lower Fonda
st. Anna I jelly fam co-created require
James has witnessed up close the growth
of a brand moving before as the nephew
of rap star Juelz Santana he observed
his uncle father and superstar hip-hop
artist Cam'ron aggressively and
successfully grow their diplomats music
label growing up and being around the
music business and stuff like that it
shows you that like everything coincides
together like music and basketball is
like one thing fashion and music and
fashion and basketball job was always a
special kid he always seemed like he was
one of us already even at that age the
whistle video during that time even
being so young he always it's just like
walk in the room and just get the
attention of everybody and we fight it's
what I do
that's that was his attitude and I'm
saying we had to kind of like okay plan
chop was a grown man at 3 years old you
know he's been around The Diplomats is
our prom and his father's a cool guy
that's uncle druthers of cool guy so he
got a lot of cool being young my career
was kind of taking off at the same time
so I just kind of kept out close with me
and just you never really treating him
like a kid he was always just treating
him like he's one of us
he was around and seen us fight file
labeled file own company at first nobody
want to saju Ellis nobody want to side
you so what I did was saying look we fly
we know how to route we got a great
image let's put out a mixed a where the
first artist that made our own mixtape
let's say we don't need to DJ and it
worked even fit he said followed the
format and he started making g-gonna
mixtape and people started loving and
g-unit mixtapes zsa was around all that
he's seen the
guerilla marketing if I know we go into
a basketball game you know let's all
promote it from this Sunday even if
there's two weeks from now cuz now
everybody gonna see it so now when we
come to the gym the gym is fully packed
everybody there now we're the trending
topic for the next week now we do the
same thing for another game or another
high school game now we plan in return
the topic for another week and now it's
like oh jellyfish jelly fam and
everybody just keeps seeing it now
that's where we add today as jelly fan
begins to make its mark on the national
stage the group feels the brand stock
will rise now the one caller that's even
more publicity meaning more fans so I
think it's gonna get bigger and bigger
multiple of us make its den be a thing
we could have a brand in the future
potentially create own store like I
think sky is the limit I think we all
gonna go to the NBA I believe that we're
gonna make our own brand have own
company want to be like get out there
get out there
once we're like free and adults I think
this thing is gonna blow up being around
my uncle being around cam like you see
them like they always had their own
customized clothing news customized
sneaker just stuff like that just makes
you want to be creative now I want to
have our like eventually like in the
future I want to have our own sneaker
like a jelly famous sure this is pretty
incredible I don't her gang movements
drug movements music movements of
radical party movements
black panther white supremacists without
me he wanted name but for these kids to
come together and treat a basketball
movement else great marketing and I
don't even know that they realize how
good marketing watch from my coach he
always told me you're gonna be doing
marketing when you get to college I just
hit them laugh but I think about it like
I could really I would just kill it
[Music]
there's something we never see what
they're doing is they're paving the way
for basketball cruised now could be a
different city or growing up underneath
them or whether they recruited before me
to perceive to be part of jelly-filled
whatever they're doing is genius I'll
tell you that is geez
[Music]
and I should add up and I'm gonna drop
[Music]
I didn't
[Music]
this is savvy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]